how to appear charismatic even if you're
not some of the favorite insights I got
from this one was when you meet someone
for the first time and they ask what you
do they don't actually care about what
you do what they're asking for is please
give me any remotely interesting
information which I can connect with my
own life it's an opportunity for you to
give an engaging and interesting answer
which can leave a good impression and
lead to a fun conversation you could say
like I'm in sales now but I did two
psychology degrees at University and
then I dropped my life and went to
Brazil for six months and I've got a
business coaching thing online but I
really just want to retire and spend my
time with dogs and start a film School
in that there are so many different
little points that the other person can
grab onto those are the most interesting
ways I think you have to have a little
pre-prepared script you know when
someone says to you what do you do you
already know what you're going to say
just make the thing that you're going to
pre-prepare more interesting